in the cold white north of Minnesota
there's a place that will get you warm
after a long day on the ice you can do
some fishing
or have a tasty beverage and it's
something of a dream for Josie I've
always wanted to own a neighborhood bar
and we finally do mine's just sitting on
a frozen lake ice fishing is a way of
life around here for people it gets so
cold below zero temps quite often which
allows us to drive and put houses out
and drill holes in the lake and fish
when it gets cold enough in the early
winter
Josie's husband goes out and tests the
ice to make sure it's thick enough
if it is they can put the bar together
and then the ice whole can open the ice
here is so thick that this bar sits on
top of it to come to our bar on the lake
you just drive your car out on the ice
and park we don't have a parking lot you
just park wherever you want walk in and
have a beer
people like to fish and drink beer and
from our bar here you can do that all at
the same time the local favorite drink
here is called the minnow shot people
will actually take a live middle which
is fishing bait and put it into their
shot and drink it as delicious is that
seafood beverage sounds people come just
because the fact that the bar exists is
pretty amazing people's reactions to
this bar are from crazy to they don't
understand it that's the coolest thing
ever
they come from all over the world to see
it it's very seasonal we're only open 20
days if you're ever near like light a
drive out on the ice Park come into the
bar and grab a pole
[Music]
you